guten morgen dass er drin nachdem ich
schon zweimal zu frau renate wurde der
perfekten deutschen hausfrau dachte ich
wäre es doch mal ganz interessant so ein
tag als wirkliche hausfrau zu verbringen
und bevor ihr wütender hausfrauen in
ihrer tastatur einklappen möchten dass
es nicht böse gemeint ich möchte mich
über niemanden lustig machen das ist
einfach nur ein kleines experiment für
mich selber so als frauen insgesamt
haben wir ja noch nicht lange so viele
rechte wie heute klingt unglaublich ist
aber so früher musste man seinen man
fragen ob man arbeiten gehen darf und
früher war es sehr wichtig dass du
überhaupt einen mann findest und eine
familie gründen
heute haben wir viel mehr entscheidungen
wir dürfen wählen die vorstellung dass
wir früher mal nicht wählen durften ist
einfach unglaublich aber es ist so und
nachdem ich die werbung aus den 50er
jahren nach gespielt habe und frau
renate war eigentlich den gedanken
irgendwie total interessant wie weit
entfernt ich von diesem frauenbild bin
also ich habe timo schon mal was gekocht
hof geräumt war für mich wirklich so den
ganzen tag um sein wohl zu kümmern dass
es 95 und weil ich so eine gute hausfrau
bin habe ich heute morgen schon verpennt
und timo nicht den kaffee gebracht so
wie ich es mir vorgenommen haben dann
bin ich froh dass wir 2021 haben und als
kleines claim wir haben ja keine kinder
und nicht mal haustiere deswegen kann
ich diesen part nicht so wirklich
abdecken aber frau renate geht ja auch
selber zur arbeit das heißt ich werde
auch ein bisschen meinen job machen den
ich auch gerade hier tue also arbeite
ich gerade lecce league und dieses
videos gesponsert von hello
jetzt kommt so helfrich spart ihr geld
zeit und stress und so funktioniert's
wähle deine gerichte stelle dir die
perfekte box zusammen er halte deine
lieferung und krachte mit frischen
zutaten der saison höre dir ein
mittagessen schon ab 3 euro 99 pro
portion an das sagt kurt zu halloween
muss nicht mehr einkaufen und spart sich
den stress im supermarkt die rezepte
sind gut zu kochen nur hilft es sich vor
dem kochen einmal durchzulesen für mich
schlag ich zwei fliegen mit einer klappe
selber kochen ohne einkaufen zu müssen
danke kurz spare dir jetzt mit dem
rabattcode hello my wanne 50 euro auf
insgesamt 4 koch boxen alle infos dazu
in der video beschreibt
timo ja was würde jetzt eine hausfrau
machen du rauchst frühstück märz muss
jetzt so eine lunchbox oder so machen
naja ich krieg' ich war gerade so für
uns freue mich jetzt auf oder koche ich
weiß nicht was zu essen gut ich kann
mich erstmal einwohner liebst jetzt
schon ich habe einen plan ich mache eine
kleine bento box eine bento box ist ganz
praktischen maxisch nehmen ganz gut
zusammen man kann es da reinpacken was
man möchte sieht ein bisschen besser aus
als sohnemann brotdose und der
kreativität keine grenzen keine grenzen
gesetzt
kann alles rein und hier haben wir
unsere lunchboxen einmal reif mit
brokkoli und gemüse bällchen senf marion
bisschen ketchup möchte mich in gurken
quark und humus da das noch warm ist
kann ich das jetzt nicht zu machen und
kino ist letztlich im raum da drüben
deswegen dringlichen das jetzt so
[Musik]
ich habe das jetzt nicht so gemacht weil
das halt noch warm ist ist zufrieden
hast du gleich uns auch angerichtet ja
[Musik]
ja okay es weckt glücksgefühle in mir
wenn er sich so darüber freut dass
gebühren und weil timo geburtstag hatte
haben seine eltern und seine
fantastische neue kaffeemaschine gekauft
sogar nachhaltig weil die secondhand
gekauft wurde
ich will ein latte macchiato
ja gut ich werde niemals erfahren dies
ist wirklich eine hausfrau in den 50er
jahren zu sein weil sie wahrscheinlich
solche maschinen noch nicht hatten
und ganz viele andere maschinen also
doch es gab ja schon waschmaschine auf
jeden fall mit solchen geräten macht man
sich ja das leben schon leichter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
lasst sie doch ganz normal wie immer
hier aus aber so die normale vanessa
würde jetzt so machen aber das wäre ja
nicht die perfekte hausfrau bauen würde
ja schon wurde weil dort willkommen in
meinem schlafzimmer
normalerweise macht jeder seine eigene
seite aber da timo heute nichts tun muss
das mache ich natürlich beide seiten von
8 uhr herrschen ja gut aber so wie es
aussieht wenn timo sein bett macht ja
das kann ich dann doch ein bisschen
kleiner trick 17 dafür muss man nicht
mal die perfekte hausfrau sein sein bett
zu machen das wirklich sehr sehr schön
es ist nämlich so dass wenn die nach dem
aufstehen schon die erste aufgabe
erledigt habt habt euer gehirn schon das
gefühl haye wird ein guter tag ich habe
ja schon was geschafft gar der bereit
und es ist ein gutes gefühl wenn man
abends ins bett geht gemacht habe hoch
machen
weiter geht's
[Musik]
wir haben die ja gebügelt die haben ja
früher nichts erklärte timo timo trägt
zerknitterte sachen ja gut dann hole ich
jetzt mal ein beweisen
als ich mich lieber offen und ehrlich es
ist 11 55 gebügelt habt dann kann ich
mich auch gleich schon ins essen mache
nicht bügeln sonst nicht mehr aber die
hose ist schon knifflig weil ich lass
ich mich wieder komplett neu inspirieren
und fangen wir wieder an ordentlicher zu
sein vor ist echt nötig macht schon
einen unterschied so damit mein mann
auch ordentlich gekleidet in die arbeit
gehen kann
[Musik]
charity lady was ich ein gefühl der bi
ne halbe ewigkeit war nur eine halbe
stunde das ist noch ok aber für so 56 t
shirts sind aufwendig ich denke mal wenn
man ein bisschen geübt da ist dann ist
man auch schneller aber fürs bügeln gibt
es von mir
drei von fünf hausfrauen punkte
[Musik]
ja kaffee nummer drei für heute
fantastisch und jetzt gehts weiter mit
unserem sponsor helau helau faschist und
eine art lieferservice für gerichte wie
dann wöchentlich zu dir kommen und das
ist auch monatlich kündbar oder pause
war das muss man nicht jede woche machen
das ist ganz flexibel
ja und dann bekommt man solche gerichte
zugeschickt mit den passenden zutaten
ich habe mich für das mittagessen
gebratene gnocchi mit ofen zucchini
entschieden und in der box findet man
die passende tüte dann zu den passenden
gericht das ist jetzt die nummer 7 und
extra kommen noch die gekühlten sachen
gekühlten sachen bekommt man dann in
seinem beutel dass es aus 96 prozent
recyceltem papier damit dass das einfach
kühl hält und da drin gibt es nach
gebeutelt also die bestehen aus wasser
das ist aber nicht zum trinken sondern
man kann seine pflanzen dann danach
gießen oder man benutzt es einfach als
kühlbeutel also wenn man draußen mal
grillen möchte oder picknick machen
möchte und die rezepte sind ganz
unterschiedlich also man kann mit
fleisch bestellen mit fisch bestellen
vegetarisch vegan da gibt es immer eine
große auswahl und daraus sucht man sich
dann seine gerichte aus und wie gesagt
wir machen jetzt gebracht
mit oben zucchini 23 bis 35 minuten
heize den backofen auf zwar nach umluft
zucchini in dünne scheiben schneiden
kini schreiben auf einem mit backpapier
belegten wacklig verteidigen
ein esslöffel öl und die würzmischung
und jetzt kommen wir unsere bienen sind
und anpinseln das sind unsere gewürzten
zucchinis das fühlt sich schon zu sehr
nach kochen an getrocknete tomaten rot
ich kann die so in meiner für gefäß
reingeben ich habe letztes jahr zum
geburtstag politik sitting bekommen dass
es so früher stabs und pürierstab mit so
aus also mit verschiedenen aufsätzen in
den militärs die das ist die folge hatte
erzählt die kleinen freuden des lebens
geworden leute getrockneten tomaten
frischkäse knoblauch und 100 beliebig
baby gebiet hier sind soße 1 esslöffel
öl bei mittlerer hitze erwärmt nazis
darin 8 bis 9
[Musik]
wie hat es dir will ich hatte nicht
meine haselnüsse auf sie drauf
die sägen bruder aus ich hab einen
kleinen fehler gemacht hat die doppelte
menge an trockenen tomaten genommen als
man sollte für mich sehr gut
die wir wirklich very die präsentation
ist alles leute jetzt kommt der hartkäse
man würde gar nicht erkennen was das
original und was es nachgemacht ist ja
das war wirklich das problem ich hab
halt zu viele tomaten genommen die soße
in getrockneten tomaten also immer noch
gucken was das rezept sagt wie viel
gramm annehmen soll
weil ich einfach rein gekippt und das
war jetzt der fehler aber ansonsten wie
das immer noch gut aus
es sieht sehr gut aus so sie befinden
sich in einer klassischen
interviewsituation wie gefällt ihnen der
tag ist jetzt fantastisch dort versorgt
kannst aber wirken hier für sport
gemacht
lecker von farfan m wünschen guten
appetit
maike timo findet langsam gefallen an
dieser ganzen geschichte verlangt kaffee
möglich
du kannst du kannst auch nicht so ganz
mit dieser situation klar
daran merkt man aber wieder unsere
charaktere wenn das andersrum wäre würde
ich das so ausnutzen wenn der irgendwo
projekt hätte ich mache alles einen tag
meine freundin ist ja nicht so dass ich
vorhin aufgeräumt habe ich habe jetzt
einfach noch mal auf ja kein problem für
mich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zeit für ein bisschen gartenarbeit um
den kopf frei zu bekommen war ich habe
zwar keinen garten also ich habe zwei
balkonpflanzen aber ich würde jetzt
ungern auf meinem balkon gehen aber ich
habe er drin pflanzen und das ist meine
monster das war mal timos bonsai also
der sag mal richtig gut aus jetzt ist
das einzige grün ist das hier das ist
diese typische ikea preiml dies und
bisschen dünn geworden aber die schafft
das ist mein ganzer stolz eine
geigenfeige die ist auch echt groß und
war auch echt teuer müssen sagen dieser
pflanze geht es hier auch recht ich
keine ahnung was das für die pflanze ist
aber die bekommt triebe neue da hinten
eine hier eine die ging ganz schön hoch
und keine ahnung was das für die pflanze
ist aber er und die sind richtig happy
hier also das muss man sagen die sind
super glücklich
ja also weil ich sie alle gießen muss
[Musik]
ich habe tatsächlich ein mittagsschlaf
gemacht ich habe mich so gut eingelebt
und nachdem das tut aber gut gerade und
ich geschlafen und eine stunde später
bin ich aufgewacht ist ja mal so ein
handbuch für die gute ehefrau im
internet kursiert und man dachte dass es
aus einem magazin ist das housekeeping
monthly heißt von 1955 und da stehen
sachen drin die eine gute hausfrau
machen sollte
es gibt auch artikel oder leute fragen
sich ob dieses ding wirklich echt ist
scheint nicht der fall zu sein
doch die sache neben dem text
beschrieben werden passend zu dieser
zeit und ich meine wir müssen im
hinterkopf beiden dass dieser text
wahrscheinlich nicht echt ist aber hier
steht machen sie sich schick können sie
sich 15 minuten pause habe ich mein
studium schlafen sich dass sie erfrischt
sind wenn er ankommt
legen sie make up nach knüpfen sie
einwandern star seien sie fröhlich
machen würde ich interessant für ihn
tatsächlich finde ich ein paar punkte
gut und einfach auch eine gesunde
beziehung zu führen also dass der mann
diese punkte auch befolgen könnte aber
ja eigentlich dachte ich dass sich das
bild der deutschen hausfrauen und es ist
unterstreichen möchte mit einem bier was
ich ihm abends sehr wie ihre frauen
haben bhs verbrannt damit ich film
freuen
ich war einkaufen und warum es plötzlich
zu so einem bock get ready myvideo
geworden ist weiß ich auch nicht also
wie mein ratgeber steht soll ich mich
jetzt natürlich schick machen und nicht
nur was leckeres kochen sondern auch
lecker aussehen ist frisch ein bisschen
mein make-up auf ganz klassisches abend
make up für den mann perfekt und schon
bin ich ready für den abend mir ist
heute auf jeden fall noch mal klar
geworden was ist eigentlich für ein job
ist für ein fulltime job meine schwester
hat viele kinder deswegen überrascht es
mich nicht weil es ja von ihr
mitbekommen aber an einem wochentag
aufzuräumen zu kochen irgendwie zu
gucken dass alles da ist die menschen im
haushalt zu versorgen das ist
das ist viel und natürlich kann man es
ein bisschen übertreiben so wie ich und
die 50er jahre ein bisschen aufs korn
nehmen und zu sagen ach ja und für
meinen mann muss jetzt am ende des tages
noch schön aussehen das entspricht ja
heute nicht mehr der wahrheit also und
wenn es der wahrheit entspricht dann ist
es ganz schön übertrieben den man den
ganzen tag gekocht und geputzt hat
sollte man abends zu wenig aussehen als
ob man irgendwie gar keine anstrengung
hatte ich frag mich einfach nur den
ganzen tag wie machen dass frauen die
beides machen
wie schaffen es frauen kinder zu
versorgen arbeiten zu gehen und den
haushalt zu schmeißen und nicht jeden
tag schon um 18 uhr irgendwie völlig
platt ins bett zu fallen musste heute
auch immer wieder an meine mama denken
da man als kind ja doch relativ
undankbar ist wenn es zum beispiel
zweimal die woche das gleiche zu essen
gibt oder irgendwie ständig das gleiche
gilt wenn man sagt man ihn nicht schon
wieder darüber wie vor stellen würde
sich für andere jeden tag etwas
ausdenken muss zum kochen
also einfach nur respekt an alle mütter
da draußen ihr seid der wahnsinn was ihr
stimmt und wenn man sich leisten kann
inzwischen auch total schön irgendwie
ein paar jahre mit den kindern und der
familie zu hause zu haben und nicht in
seinen doppelten stress zu haben aber
das kann sich ja heutzutage auch kaum
eine familie leisten würden sich die
mieten anguckt es müssen beide arbeiten
und dann müssen irgendwie die kinder
versorgt katastrophe wenn ich auf eine
existenzkrise grad
willkommen zum großen finale hier in
vanessas küche und zum abendessen
serviert hähnchenkeulen mit
knollensellerie stampf bunten ofen
karotten und balsamico soße das sind
viele staaten und da sind dann gesagt
dass ich hier total spannend finde sind
die lila nennt karotten die kenne ich
nicht also also ich kenne sie aber ich
habe ich glaube ich noch nie probiert
und hier sind die normalen
diese kinder sollten jetzt langsamer
schlag mehr viele leute mögen es nicht
rohes fleisch zu sehen deswegen zeige
ich euch die hähnchenkeulen nicht aber
eine sache und ob jetzt mir glaubt oder
nicht aber er läuft falsch ist wirklich
die perfekte partner für dieses video
weil wenn ich noch die zutaten alle
zusammen hätte sammeln müssen oder
einkaufen müsste dann wäre das ganz
schön viel gewesen deswegen ja hallo
fresh das gemüse und die hähnchenkeule
waschen karotten schneiden den stamm
vorbereiten soße zubereiten stammt
vollenden anrichten
[Musik]
das land für die kirche danke danke und
präsentieren wollen
[Musik]
und hier für mich okay probier auf jeden
fall die märchen
[Musik]
diese moleküle aussieht
ein schlachtfeld
[Musik]
wenn die kamera ist gerade beim aufbauen
ausgegangen aber hier ist der
videobeweis es ist aufgeräumt ich habe
wieder alles sauber gemacht ich bin so
kaputt es ist 9 uhr und es fühlt sich an
als ob ein uhr nachts war die wohnung
des sauber wir sind alle satt und
glücklich und die perfekte hausfrau
macht jetzt feierabend ich gucke jetzt
einen film geht dann ins bett und mein
fazit
so sind jetzt ein paar tage seit dem
experiment vergangen und nicht kann
sagen das ist auf jeden fall sehr sehr
interessant war und sehr sehr
anstrengend diese ganze geschichte also
wenn beide partner arbeiten dann müssen
sich auch wirklich beide den haushalt
und alle aufgaben teilen weil sonst ist
es nur und wenn du da draußen eine
hausfrau oder ein hausmann bist danke
dass ihr euch für die familie so
aufopfert danke tschüss und bis dann
abonniert main kanal und aktiviert die
glocken der gibt ein daumen nach oben
bei